It's Mark Wiens here. I am in Khorat, Thailand and I am at a really popular restaurant
Called Kanom Jeen Kru Yawd. It is a huge restaurant.
You can see like it actually looks like it was once just a house. But it looks like they just kept expanding and expanding and expanding
that its just grown into epic proportions
So this place is huge and they are really famous for serving a dish called khanom jeen
Which are the slightly fermented fresh rice noodles and they come with curry but I've also ordered a few extra dishes
Can't wait to eat
Oh, God
So this is one of the types of khanom jeen called kanom jeen nam ya
Which is a coconut milk-based gravy should be some fish in there as well
Those are the rice noodles there, and this one here is just gaeng gai
Which is just chicken curry and that is a big lump of blood
Gelatinous jelly. One of the things that's really awesome about eating khanom jeen
is that it's always served with a, an entire gardens worth of vegetables
raw vegetables on the side and you can either put the vegetables
Directly on top of your khanom jeen or you can just eat khanom jeen and then sort of garnish your mouth
Every few bites with some of the vegetables. I think this is lemon basil. Should be lemon basil
cabbage, bean sprouts, long beans
maybe pok boon or
umm or
morning glory, and then this is shaved up umm "hua plee" which is a
banana flower, we not only ordered "khanom jeen"
But we also got a couple of extra protein sides this place is very well known for their "gai tod"
umm just fried chicken wings
And they are like smoldering hot right out of the oil and also I got a "pla pao" which is a roasted roasted fish
salt-crusted
I have made a recipe for this "pla pao", so if you want to click right here
umm you can check out the recipe of how you can make this "pla pao" at home
It's an awesome awesome thai way to grill a fish. I'm gonna go straight in for the "nam ya"
mmmmm....oh
ohh
thats delightful. There's a real flavor in there that I
can really taste there's a certain flavor, but I'm not even sure what that is
It's like a little bit bitter
But like salty and sweet at the same time this is a common type of "khanom jeen"
But I normally have the southern Thai style. Which is a little bit different which uses more turmeric and
More thicker coconut milk, so this is a little bit different style
So I'm not sure exactly what that distinct taste is but it's awesome. I just had Ying taste it and
She told me that it is "krachai" and that yeah, that is exactly what it is. She is good
It's similar to ginger, but at the same time. It's not quite as pungent as ginger. I think
Yet it maybe has a little...it has the same kind of earthy flavor to it earthy root slightly spicy
root flavor to it. That banana flower
And a little bit of the lemon basil to top it off. Oh beautiful!  I'm going to go for that chili this bite too. oh yeah
grab one of these guys
mmmmm
That's just lightly salted and then fried fresh and crisp
That's just a good solid chicken wing I think it would be even better if I dipped it quickly in the curry sauce
Oh, yeah, that's good
put on some veg
it's more of like a sweet and salty creamy curry and
Tastes a little bit like a "kiew wan". Which is the green curry Thai green curry but only it's like pink in color instead
That's good as well, but I really like that nam ya better
I'm just gonna get a piece of fish add some sauce
I'm meeting him right off,  right off the...the bone
mmmmm
I just love fish cooked this way...pla pao
Just always amazing as long as it's not overcooked which this one is not
ummm. It's just fantastic. Just a meaty
Flaky oily fish...the sauce is not the best I've had it is sour but not very spicy
But the fish is excellent. These are sai gua. Which is the lotus lotus stems, so
You can almost use it like a straw
a whole bunch of water just came out of that
I usually have this in a curry, umm a coconut milk curry but by itself right now it actually has zero flavor
yeah...has zero flavor
It's like eating. It's kind of like celery actually has that crispness, but really basically no flavor to it
Grab some of this pla pao and I'm going to put it right into my curry
mmm
That is awesome
Great khanom jeen
And I especially loved the nam ya version with that [inaudible] as as I am sitting here
Just like busloads of people are showing up for lunch here, so this place is
Yeah, like I said this place is a. it's an institution in Khorat. I I guess they're famous for a reason the food is fantastic
This is a such an awesome herb. It tastes like
You're eating like dish soap, but good awesome. Fresh dish soap
that's probably not the best description I've ever made but just
kind of think of it as dish soap that's awesome.
I love all this mixture of
I had to burp real fast. Oh, oh that was a delicious burp. Anyway, that...that flavor that earthy tone of cra chai
ohhh...you missed it
Hey, it's Mark wiens here
Thank you for watching this video, and if you enjoyed it make sure you give it a thumbs up and share it with a friend
click on one of the thumbnails to keep watching more videos and if you're not already subscribed
You got to get subscribed right now, so you don't miss more delicious food and travel videos, Okay, l'll see you on the next video